ce sont de vieilles habitudes répéter
tous les ans à seulement 15 minutes du
début de l'épreuve de philosophie les
temps de vérifier et distribuer les
copies selon les filières
les surveillants et enseignants sont eux
dispatchés dans les classes de leur côté
les élèves s'installent à 8 heures
précises les épreuves écrites du
baccalauréat 2010 8 commence le lycée
tout entier passe alors en mode exams
je passais de salle en salle pour voir
si tout se passe bien faire voir les
professeurs ci s'il n'y a pas de
problème
essayer de rassurer tout le monde
puisque c'est aussi une épreuve même
pour les professeurs sont les leurs
élèves qui vont passer le baccalauréat
donc voilà elles sont aussi un peu
stressée je pense général ou
technologique plus de 300 candidats ont
passé leur première épreuve à montigny
le bretonneux
après plus de trois heures de
concentration et d'efforts les première
réaction a été plutôt contrastée s'est
pas franchement je sais pas philo c'est
vraiment une matière où on peut dire oui
à pro finalement et donc le versement
donc voilà je me suis débrouillé je
pense assez bien je pense j'ai réussi et
on attend de voir la suite
le deuxième sujet c'était sur la justice
et j'étais pas du tout à l'aise sur moi
je voulais la vérité ou le désir est là
juste la chance de tomber sur le désir
que j'étais très contente
c'était pas trop difficile mais après je
pense pas avoir réussi tant que ça
réussit ou loupé les bacheliers n'ont
plus le temps de méditer sur la
philosophie demain matin place à
l'histoire géographie